l'inversion des valeurs c'est quand les
policiers sont désignés coupables et les
casseurs innocents l'inversion des
valeurs c'est quand les minorités
actives dictent la loi à la majorité
silencieuse l'inversion des valeurs
c'est quand la chiant Lee devient la
règle et l'autorité
l'exception moment d'échangir soir à
l'Olympia entre la chanteuse norvégienne
girl in red et son public et quand
l'artiste de 24 ans demande qu'on lui
apprenne quelques mots en français voilà
le résultat
la foule cri en cœur Macron démission et
prend de cours la jeune femme
visiblement un peu perdu sur scène
vous allez nous faire une petite séance
de rattrapage des poissons d'avril sur
les réseaux bah oui parce que comme tous
les ans des marques des médias ou encore
des monuments ils sont allés de leur
annonce farfelus ce week-end par exemple
la Tour Eiffel Camille en ligne une
vidéo annonçant l'installation d'un
toboggan le plus haut du monde qui
s'enroulerait autour de la Dame de Fer
oui c'est évidemment faux mais c'est
très tentant
[Rires]
ils vont devoir rivaliser l'imagination
dans un seul but époustoufler leur
convives ça c'est fait pour moi tout est
bon je trouve ça excellent moi je
termine mon assiette direct vous
retrouverez Etienne le baroudeur de
Pékin Express moi j'ai rien compris qui
proposera un voyage en Grèce je pense
que ça peut pas être très long du côté
des marques ce sont les fast food qui se
sont distingués cette année Burger King
c'est moqué des frites de légumes
désormais proposés chez McDo on rigole
poisson d'avril imaginez si quelqu'un
faisait ça écrit Burger King KFC a même
imaginé le lancement d'un panier de
brocolis le bucket Broco évidemment là
aussi poisson d'avril toujours
autant j'avoue le le grand toboggan de
la Tour Eiffel je veux bien le bucket
brocoli alors c'est quoi votre
mystérieux dessert Étienne
avec une espèce de petite mousse avec du
yaourt grec on va essayer de faire
mousser un petit peu tout ça pour que ce
soit pas trop pâteuse oui le but c'est
de se faire mousser pour remporter la
victoire avec ce voyage du Lys
mais bon je sais pas trop ce que je vais
faire après j'en sais rien on verra en
revanche contrairement à ce que beaucoup
ont pu croire ce week-end les photos de
Marlène Schiappa dans le magazine
Playboy ne sont pas un poisson d'avril
elles existent bel et bien mais moi
j'aime bien le fait qu'elle aille dans
les boy tout le monde lui est tombé
dessus le président parle à pivget
Marlène Schiappa pousse dans Playboy
Olivier du soft est à la une du journal
têtu allez-y mesdames messieurs
continuez détruisez des construisez
décrédibiliser n'hésitez pas quand on a
dépassé les bornes il n'y a plus de
limite si beaucoup ont d'abord cru à une
blague le magazine de charme connu
notamment pour ses clichés érotiques
après bien assortir une longue interview
de la secrétaire d'État accompagnée de
quelques photos où elle évoque la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
l'IVG ou encore les droits LGBT de faire
Nadine Morano est-ce que vous
accepteriez de poser nu dans Playboy
je cautionne totalement l'édito que vous
avez fait de leur côté les membres de la
majorité la première ministre mais aussi
de nombreux opposants politiques ont
fustigé la secrétaire d'État présente en
une du magazine alors que les
protestations contre la réforme des
retraites font rage moi j'ai
l'impression d'un écran de fumer entre
ça têtu Pif Gadget je sais pas
maintenant on va avoir un épisode de
Goldorak avec les membres du
gouvernement Emmanuel Macron a décidé de
donner une grande interview dans Hot
Vidéo comment je vais vous déglinguer
l'année prochaine
Eric Dupont-Moretti s'exprimera dans
charges utile le magazine des camions de
collection Franck Riester dans la
Gazette du vent et des éoliennes Olivier
du soft va parler de négociation avec
les syndicats dans Karaté Bushido et
Elisabeth borne posera seins nus dans
féminin Seigneur pour une grande
interview sur le pouvoir d'achat
intitulé avec l'inflation on finira tous
à poil est-ce que de Playboy fait partie
des vôtres monsieur l'archet je pense
que ça n'était pas opportun mais je
crois quelqu'un l'a dit avant moi
c'était pas du tout la question Gérard
vous demandez si vous étiez déjà
triturer le Big Sur Playboy
c'était pas son jour il avait pas envie
de répondre parler de Chapa ça fait
énormément parler donc vous le coup est
réussi
au gouvernement Elizabeth borne a jugé
la démarche très inappropriée Gérald
Darmanin de son côté a préféré lui
envoyer un texto disant hey canon la
miss et moi qui croyais qu'on avait
livré tous nos obus à l'Ukraine
à part la promotion de ses cheveux et la
promotion de sa gueule elle fait la
promotion de rien du tout et je le
trouve ouais non excuse-moi je la trouve
pas très très efficace et tu tombes dans
l'excès toi
moi j'estime que la fonction de soit
secrétaire d'État soit de déléguer c'est
une fonction qui est quand même
prestigieuse que tu représentes la
France et excuse-moi qu'elle soit pas à
poil qu'elle soit pas folle numéro 2 je
suis pas sûr que les enfin que ceux qui
les lecteurs de Playboy ou ceux qui
aiment les photos de charme avait très
envie d'avoir Marlène
non
ça me gêne pas que Marlène Schiappa
fasse la une de Playboy tout ce que je
demande c'est qu'elle fasse pas de
stand-up alors moi j'étais content que
j'ai appelé toute ma famille
elle nous ferait presque regretter
textes on a des femmes qui meurent tous
les jours sur les coups de leur mari on
a parlé quelques semaines ici avec on
avait le même plateau et tu me poses sur
Playboy mais c'est pas de tu as pas
autre chose de mieux à faire dans ta vie
quand même pour les femmes et pour la
santé c'est du buzz et encore une fois à
part la promotion de sa propre gueule à
elle elle fait la promotion de rien du
tout et enfin le grand gagnant c'est
monsieur qui arrive à partir de René
Char pour arriver à René du Balto
disait René Char c'est à dire
l'essentiel est toujours menacé par
l'insignifiant là où on y est moi je
dirais quand on assume de passer dans ce
genre magazine c'est que votre jugé sur
son physique donc moi je me prononcerai
quand j'aurai vu Playboy voilà pour ce
top 3 au revoir